let's get deep for a minute and talk
about a topic that is incredibly
important in the world of motion design
money mindset maybe you've heard the
myth that to make it in this industry
you have to work for low pay pay your
dues and then one day you'll start to
earn decent money but if you're looking
to get rich good luck the truth is this
kind of thinking is toxic and will only
hold you back you are talented have a
high paying skill and worthy of earning
the money you think you deserve but to
earn the money you think you're worthy
of you need to first start valuing
yourself because when you believe in
your worth you attract higher paying
clients who value you just as much as
you do you can achieve incredible
success and financial abundance if
you're willing to shift your mindset